[Music]
oaster
the oaster somebody said the other day
in his comments that he looks like um
like a sh version of uh the big lebowski
so then i i i replied with the douche
abides
so uh we're gonna skip around a little
bit in this video but uh the upstairs uh
coming back i love love the way he's
looking he's looking great can i make a
prediction
sure dude i don't even care anymore
i've seen the videos guys like they keep
talking about me
man and i'm like dude i'm so bro i'm
so over that like i'm so
beyond over it man it's like i was doing
this when i was 18. i
need anthony man pretty pretty dead on
it's actually not a bad opie yeah that's
not a bad hobby
uh i just everybody needs to move on
dude like i did when i sold shirts with
my dead friend
and kept the money so let's check it out
what 500 feet off the ground
overlooking uh kind of the hudson river
in the background and also
a little bit of midtown manhattan right
now
la potencia you are first on the youtube
my friend
uh welcome to our sorry little live
stream uh eric venom's in the chat says
looks like aew chris jericho now
no he looks like chris jericho if he
never left wcw
and then wwe didn't pick them up
remember that
they had all those that russia guys that
came in when they acquired wc to
like if you had stayed in wcw with mark
gintrack and sean stacy you know what i
mean
this is the chris jericho that got
released in 2001
and is doing doing hannibal tv [ __ ]
shoot interviews
monday on monday evening what's that
about
sash or satch what's going on man you're
uh you're spinning around a little bit i
think we're at the end of the road me
and you brother
i gave you uh i gave you a few days to
hate here we go
from there sir here you go by the way a
happy birthday to uh
hope you get less views than steve grill
i i i
oh yeah is it you yagi yagi i think
we're at the end of the road me and you
brother
i gave you uh i gave you a few days to
hate hate all you want but
if that's all you're gonna do with this
i i think i think we're at the end of
the road what do you think yogi
you want to give it one last bam before
i block you
because right now i see uh 266 people
are checking this out right now that is
that is a healthy number for me right
now
wasn't opioids not though you were on
radio
yeah you should have explosive thousands
yeah
um there's no reason we should
consistently be able to
snap our fingers and draw a bigger crowd
than you yeah that's that shouldn't be
um also wasn't opie always the [ __ ]
like teetotaler of the crew
yes why does he look like he's just done
nothing but drinking and smoking
since i'm gonna say this but out of the
two anthony
is looking better than opie yeah by the
same age anthony's also got teams of
professionals constantly going
also i got to concede though i i'm i'm
we [ __ ] on opie a lot
it's a goddamn nice view though i'm
jealous
of you i'm very jealous of that view
i don't know how many on the youtube but
uh between the facebook and
and uh youtube i get the uh the total
number we're at 260
we just lost one so now we're at 265 so
so oh god imagine noticing that uh
and oh and i'm getting a huge stick
laugh through the pain for myself that's
for sure
sometimes i guess you gotta do things
for other people right
get some guests and some shiznit a lot
of people from northern minnesota talk
like
that they almost sound like uh boomhauer
howard from
king oh from king of the hill no kidding
no
i i do not um
do you think you might have her mental
illness referring to his mom
my mom was mentally ill i offered up all
that info man maybe i should have kept
that [ __ ] to myself but
no i've been uh i've been on that [ __ ]
for a very very long time my friends i
uh you know i've been in therapy for
well over 10
10 plus years i got to go maybe even you
know therapy works because you have to
keep going back to it for 10 years
they say that well you know honestly
that's why therapy's such a [ __ ] scam
in the first place because
therapy is this thing it's like
scientology it's set up to
where you just ne you never reach the
final level
it's always set up to where you got to
keep going no you got to keep going it's
a
it's a constant it's like not dude this
is why i don't buy therapy i don't mind
like
going to a psychiatrist or something and
having them diagnose you
but when you just go to a therapist it's
such a [ __ ] middle class
waspy whiny [ __ ] i'm not happy with
my what my mom treated me
a bit short of that and uh so after my
year was up i skipped
absolutely wanted me to stay we had a
really nice crew it was me
robert a little foot obviously
little foot then there was joey salvia
who was
absolutely amazing and then there was uh
tim
sabian and uh a lot
and more sat me down they're like we
could we could do a revenue share with
you and at that point i'm like ah
cause uh i i knew that and i'm sorry
paul
they offered him a rev share
no no no let me tell you rev share is
not if you're good you don't take the
rev
share deal you know yeah we've we've
turned that [ __ ] down with
sponsors before where they're like oh
you want to do like a nice uh
revenue share commission we're like no
you're going to pay us because
pretty good audience that's going to
hear about your [ __ ] stupid product
um also isn't it weird when you see
these guys like
that guy dank lord whoever the [ __ ] that
is i'm sure compared to opie doesn't
have a pot to piss in
you're staring at a [ __ ]
multi-million dollar view
and you're giving this guy 25 bucks it
just seems silly to me
like i'm not saying you know somebody
how much money somebody has like
if a streamer you enjoy has a lot of
money it's not like oh well i'm not
going to donate [ __ ] him
of course you donate if you like the
content but like
wouldn't you try to like let's say you
had millions of dollars
and you're doing your show wouldn't you
still try to remain kind of like
would you start just flossing on camera
with your v
like would you just kind of play it down
and be like yeah me doing my show man
it's funny because i have a time stamp
for that too we're coming to that point
to answer your question you'll see go
off on my own and uh
you know i hired a little a little
company to sell ads for my
my podcast and i'm honestly making about
the same i would have at uh
at westwood one and then and then at
that point you know i knew everyone was
sort of uh
leaving to go do other things and since
then uh i left tim sabian left carl died
vic died uh mike sappho is uh
still doing his his thing and helping me
out when he can and littlefoot left
for a huge gig with cnn and their and
their podcasts over there i think i
could say that
so yeah i wouldn't go back to westwood
one but i wish them nothing but the best
but it wasn't fired or anything like
that haters like to spin
because it wasn't a job i simply told
you the truth and and
it'll still be spun they just didn't
want to pay me the
the pretty decent salary to be honest
with you
they didn't want to pay so you you
weren't worth the amount they were
paying you
so you were what's the
the word i'm looking for
he was [ __ ] he was something for a
revenue share which would have meant my
money would have been um
cut drastically so uh 25
what does this guy say it's been on the
screen a while brother man isn't it sad
that the only way jim
jimmy and ann can pull views is by
trashing you it's the only way they
could stay relevant still
waiting for days you guys leave it alone
and get back together big
payday i don't i don't need a big payday
there my friend
uh open you look so tired
it's cool being old you [ __ ] with a
haircut and no
[ __ ] shower see the see this is uh
this is what i have to deal with like
what i don't get is how do you how do
you
so you guys you you so you so got fire
got fired you so got fired i
also i gotta point out i love that he's
like i didn't shower i haven't even done
like hey i didn't get my hair cutting
with okay
you're unemployed and you have money and
you're like like
you can't take a shower no you have time
though to do that
it's like it's like if somebody was like
oh yeah you know it's like saying you
don't have time to work out or you don't
have time to take a shower you don't
have time to take care of yourself
when you're unemployed it's like now you
have more time than ever to take care of
you
so i skipped to this time stamp which is
a good one skip ahead for a second
um i don't think
i don't think jim ever met my dad but he
met my mom
why can't you just ignore the trolls
hope come on dude yeah it's a little
troll heavy tonight i'm not gonna lie to
you
um it happens it's like a catch-22
though because
if i talk about the ona [ __ ] my numbers
are way uh way higher
probably twice as high usually of course
they are um
but i don't really want to do that on a
regular basis but uh i
i do know it gets the numbers up so it's
welcome to youtube
on the one hand i don't want to sit here
and just keep talking about this one
[ __ ] thing all the time
on the other hand the minute i deviate
and start to express how i feel to my
audience
they all turn on me welcome to youtube
pal
we get welcome to the world of do duo
and benjamin moore yep welcome buddy
richard cox jr forget all the haters
hope your fans got your back at bear
that's right i'm getting my son of a
peach beer from richard cox jr by the
way richard
cox jr probably makes 31 000
a year no i'm not i'm not sure you know
what i mean i'm not [ __ ] on his
income but it's like you're giving 20 of
that
to this guy who has again this view
he's unbelievably expensive to have a
place that has that kind of a view
it's a very expensive view time for
memorial day weekend
uh yeah i'm meeting you what uh i think
we got to meet now thursday right there
richard
yeah we'll figure it out and here it is
richard's one of the good guys
he has that son of a peach beer from
south carolina that i really really like
oh my god like it a lot wow and uh they
don't
uh it's not in any of the beer
distributors up this way
so uh richard's coming for the memorial
day weekend and he brought me a few
cases that's how nice these people are
more people would hear if you yelled out
the window that's not true
it's such a mean comment it really is
it's a very mean comment
bar and by the way barbara thompson i've
got a feeling barbara's not a
she i haven't feeling old barbara
thompson
it just feels like the old barb is
probably a guy behind that account
i'm still pushing just under 400 people
right now
an hour into this that's crazy
that's good numbers mm-hmm
i i don't know what a i don't know what
a what p
uh watp is comment on
yes comments on carl from watp i
literally don't know what that is oh
you're right i bet yeah sure
sure you don't you're lying
yeah you [ __ ] liar who's carl
who's that guy oh [ __ ] man uh
[Music]
all right i think we did it wow okay no
we didn't because now we have something
else that i wanted to play yeah i
love those like i don't even know who
that guy is
back up just a little bit here we go all
right still talk to brother wheeze
pretty much on a regular basis
pretty much like on a weekly basis
he's getting way the [ __ ] up there and
he still
[ __ ] crushes it on the radio my
goodness
crushes it in one market radio our other
reese outlived opie on the radio though
he did now this next question yeah but
there's long there is longevity in doing
the whole
morning coffee club radio
it just it is it's safer
uh all right let's see
you don't need money hope how do you
know how do you know my finances
i actually do need money i'm not i'm not
crying poverty
but i haven't really made uh real money
in four or five years
i need money like anyone else you piece
of
garbage of course i do
uh oh and if people want to give me a
few bucks to live stream and
when i see uh that i make a few bucks it
keeps me very motivated to do this great
and if they don't want to give me money
that's okay too
obi the reason people are saying you
don't need money is that you built this
mystique around you and you go i don't
need to do this remember he was like i
don't need this his job anymore i'm
doing fine
i invested wisely i don't need to do
this you're the one that made people
think you don't need money dude
yeah any like honestly even if you did
invest wisely i was saying this off the
air to royce like even if you invest
wisely and you saved a bunch of money
and you're
you're investing and all that stuff
right if you live in new york city
new york city thank you uh if you live
in new york city
you will um inevitably run out of money
of course it's just their tax rate is is
set up to bleed you so it's like what
you're going to pay 40
what was the estimate remember when they
said the buying tax plan was gonna be
like sixty percent of your money when
you
go to taxes so it's like you're doing
that even the money you've already
earned
if you use that money to invest and earn
more money you're still paying to it
never ends
now if you're taking that open op if
you're taking that big big dick money
uh down to florida like everyone said
anthony should have done either the
texas or florida
you could have lived like an afghani
[ __ ] opium warlord for the rest of
your life
but you guys wanted to have that new
york life so yeah now you have no money
it's what happens
dude if i had somebody gave me [ __ ]
millions of dollars right now
i'd go to new york again much more often
i'd probably go to new york all the time
but you better believe that the last
thing i'd ever do if i had a bunch of
money was go
i'm gonna restructure my life so i'm
based in new york
and he also makes sense to be fair he
invested on that that business fh
riley's you know he's probably bringing
in the dough right
hey royce so about a year and a half ago
this thing called covet broke out
okay and restaurants are not allowed to
really make any money anymore oh
okay ma'am
pause okay james you're just spamming
the same comment i
i i even put you on the big screen and
we won't be consistently bitching about
having a talk about o
a the only reason anyone knows and cares
who you are talk about it
all right i think we got to say goodbye
to james
good bye bye james
see you in two seconds
bye james slash barbara yeah roland does
suck
for real he really [ __ ] sucks but
because you filmed him taking his [ __ ]
yeah you filmed it's his fault i'm not
saying i like rogan rolling rolling but
you feel him taking his [ __ ] dude
what do you think but i do thank him
because i think he was the one
between him and guy fieri that
introduced me to uh to carl but
roland really does [ __ ] suck
for real like we were including him
and everything rolling and like filming
people in the bathroom
yeah like as one would do dude i was
trying to include you in our fun social
circle
and then carl took a liking to me loved
doing the show with me
and then he really liked me vic and uh
charade we became a nice little group
and we didn't shut out roland we made
sure we included him in
every [ __ ] even when he was in the
bathroom yeah you really included him
then
especially when he was in the bathroom
i've got a very few things that will
set me off like like real [ __ ] that will
make me go okay you're dead to me
and one of those things
one of those things is just bathroom
anything bathroom
um showering [ __ ]
pissing related any like that to me is
like i would never bother another person
in the bathroom
and i sure as [ __ ] will not put up with
somebody bothering me in the bed like if
i you know what i mean like that's a
time when you're supposed to be
uh you're sitting at your stupid phone
taking a dump you know what i mean
i would snap if somebody i would want
like i'm not somebody to usually go like
i want this person fired
that's one of the few times in my life
i'd probably go i
want this person fired like there's no
it's one thing if you want to like
uh you know whatever if you caught like
let's say somebody went out for a
cigarette break and somebody was filming
them and they didn't know they were
being filmed
and you get like some footage of
somebody having a cigarette maybe
they're picking their nose a little bit
or something you're like that's kind of
funny
and you play that i i would be like okay
that's fair game you know what i mean
but
he the fact that he to this day he
pretends like there's no problem what he
did it's like i would never
i'm even conscious of like having my
phone out in a bathroom
because of like dude i've seen videos of
people that are recording in bathrooms
like they walk in and they're like
not recording people they're recording
themselves in a mirror or something
but you're still in a bathroom like turn
that [ __ ] thing off
well that was an update on the upstair
that was just a quick one i mean
it's a really long video but those are
the best clips anyway from it